[Applaus]
[Musik]
willkommen liebe Zuschauer bei history
live dem historischen Quartett auf
Phönix Rätsel RF Terror darüber
diskutieren wir heute mit jeseler
Diewald Kerkmann von der Uni Bielefeld
Wolfgang grauser vom Hamburger Institut
für Sozialforschung und Bernhard Töpper
der damals für das ZDF die RAF Prozesse
begleitet hat in den 70er und 80er
Jahren wurde die Bundesrepublik vom
Terror der roten armeefraktion in Atem
gehalten gerade die wirtschaftlichen und
politischen Eliten sahen sich in hohem
Maß bedroht und mussten um ihr Leben
fürchten der RAF ist zwar Geschichte
aber viele Fragen sind noch immer offen
Frau Diewald Kerkmann was war denn die
RAF was motivierte sie was war ihr Ziel
allein um diese Frage zu beantworten
würde die heutige Sitzung nicht
ausreichen und wir haben zahlreiche
Publikationen Filme Dokumentationen
deshalb werde ich versuchen an einzelnen
Punkten vielleicht an zesuren
festzumachen also rote armeefraktion ist
nur im kon im zeithistorischen Kontext
zu verstehen vor dem Hintergrund einer
breiten Protestbewegung in der
bundesdeutschen Gesellschaft ähnliche
protestbewegen gab es in Frankreich gab
es in Italien und gab es auch in anderen
Staaten vor allem auch in den Vereinten
Staaten hieraus erwuchs am Rande nach
dem Scheitern dieser Bewegung oder
dieser einzelnen Protestbewegung
erwuchsen am Rande wuchsen einzelne
terroristische Gruppierungen für
Deutschland war es der Erl für Italien
war die Roten Brigaden für Frankreich zu
einem späteren Zeitpunkt Aktion direkt
und in den Vereinigten Staaten
weatherman es waren vielfach Mitglieder
dieser Bewegung die mehr oder weniger
aus Protest den Kampf weiterführten und
eben dazu überging dass sie das
staatliche Gewaltmonopol heraus mehr
oder wen mehr oder weniger angreifen
wollten von daher war ihr Ziel den Kamp
weiterzu führen nur jetzt eben mit
bewaffneten nur eben mit Waffen und
tatsächlich auch mit der Herausforderung
des Staates wie muss man sich das
politische Klima den damals vorstellen
Herr Töpper meiner Stichwort
Protestbewegung war da ein besonderer
Nährboden für Linken Extremismus auch
für Terrorismus am Ende ja die 68er
Studentenrevolte war ja gerade äh vorbei
war noch in lebhafter Erinnerung dann
war vor allen Dingen der Vietnamkrieg im
Gange und diese fürchterlichen Bilder
mit den verbrannten Kindern Napalmbomben
nur als Stichwort die ging jeden Abend
über die
Fernsehnachrichten und das hat mit dazu
beigetragen dass ich diese
Protestbewegung
gebildet hat und dann war auch noch
denke ich ganz wichtig dass zur
damaligen Zeit die NS Vergangenheit
vieler Eltern nicht aufgearbeitet war
und dieses ganze Konglomerat das war es
glaube ich was damals dann zur Bildung
der RAF geführt hat was sind denn heute
die wichtigsten Fragen lange Zeit danach
die offenen Fragen die es in Sachen RAF
heute immer noch gibt her kuser von
außen betrachtet würde ich sagen die
Kernfrage lautet nach vor warum ist die
ARF überhaupt gegründet worden denn man
muss sich das vorstellen das schließt
etwa an an das was zuvor Herr Töpper
gesagt hat wir befanden uns damals in
der Blütezeit der sozialliberalen
Koalition da war eine Regierung in der
Bundesrepublik an der Macht die eine
neue Ostpolitik propagiert hat die
Reformpolitik propagiert hat und genau
zu der Zeit hat sich paradoxerweise eine
terroristische Bewegung
herauskristallisiert mit dem Ziel diese
Regierung zu stürzen den Staat
anzugreifen vieles anderes mehr das ist
eigentlich nach wie vor ein
tendenzielles Rätsel aber sie meinen
vermutlich etwas anderes mit rätsell
oder rätzellen
das erste was ich sagen würde besteht
darin dass wir nach wie vor keine
Klarheit darüber haben warum der Staat
nämlich staatliche Agenten in im
damaligen Westberlin von 1967 bis 1971
insbesondere ein mannamens Peter Urbach
dafür gesorgt hat dass interessierte
Kreise versorgt worden sind mit Moll
Cocktails mit Sprengstoff und mit
Schusswaffen das heißt da haben Leute
bewusst sozusagen Öl ins Feuer gegossen
und das ist nach wie vor unaufgeklärt
das ist sozusagen der Punkt Nummer ein
den es zu klären gäbe Punkt Nummer 2 ist
der dass wir ja von einer ganzen
sogenannten Generation der dritten
Generation der RAF eigentlich überhaupt
keine Klärung der Mordtaten von 1985 bis
1991 haben das heißt insbesondere die äh
bekannten Namen herrhausenattentat
rohwetterattentat und andere mehr die
sind völlig unaufgeklärt und man tappt
da nach wie vor im Dunkeln und das sind
zwei maßgebliche Dinge die eigentlich
der Klärung bedürfen reden wir zunächst
mal über die Gründung bevor wir zu den
anderen Punkten kommen mai 1970 die
Befreiung von Andreas Bader in Berlin
worum ging es denn da wer waren die
führenden Leute sie meinen jetzt die
führenden Leute direkt der roten
armeefraktion diese Befreiungsaktion
also ich denke D wenn wir direkt Namen
nennen hab müssen wir natürlich gur
enzlin anführen g mE bei dieser
baderbefreiung war natürlich ulr
gemeinof beteiligt aber auch eine Ingrid
Schubert und auch eine astd Proll um
also einfach Namen zu nennen aber reden
wir mal über Ulrike meinof Andreas Bader
enzlin über diesei wer war das was was
motivierte sie was waren das für Leute
war eine sehr bekannte Journalistin die
jahrelang für konkret gearbeitet die
immerhin auch Chefredakteurin war die
eine sehr
wirklich schon eine sehr starke Position
insgesamt im bundesdeutschen alterag
hatte und auch
tatsächlich schon zahlreiche Artikel
geschrieben hat die auch auf starke
Akzeptanz stßen in der Gesellschaft das
waren also keine außenseiterpition Kuron
enlin war eine Germanistikstudentin vor
die hinterher zum Zeitpunkt auch ein
Promotionsvorhaben vorhatte die durch
die A 60er Bewegung nicht zuletzt auch
durch die Erschießung B ohne Sorg was
wir auch nicht vergessen dürfen auch
eben 1967 stark politisiert wurde und
letztlich auf der durch diese starke
Politisierung auch eine zunehmende
Radikalisierung erfuhr obwohl man immer
bei Rud enchen sagen muss dass sie auch
in der Wahlkampfhilfe für die SPD
beteiligt war das das wird vielfach aus
der Acht gelassen dass sie wirkich auch
einen langen prozessvollzoch der
Politisierung Andreas Bader äh ich finde
er fällt etwas aus der Gruppe raus bei
den anderen handelt es vifach um
intellektuelle um Studenten oder
einzelne die auch bereits ab ihr Studium
abgeschlossen haten wir ingrd Schubert
oder
horstmerer er war jemand der mehr oder
weniger sich in Kleinkriminellen
Delikten auch
mehr oder weniger beheimatet war in
Anführungszeichen wobei wobei man
allerdings schon sagen muss dass er im
Laufe der Zeit auch in der
Untersuchungshaft
sich schon auch sch verstärk mit ischen
Texten auseinandergesetzt hat also er
muss auch schon wandlungspro was brachte
diese Menschen zum Terrorismus was
brachte diese Menschen zum Terrorismus
das Bader ja im Gefängnis saß weil er
68 in Frankfurt zwei Kaufhäuser mit
angezündet hatte und er saß also im
Gefängnis und die anderen wollten ihn
befreien das damit ging es los genau was
brachte diese Menschen dann von dieser
Befreiung Anfang dann richtig in den
regelrechten harten Terrorismus was war
das was war das ich glaube hauptsächlich
wurde es damals begründet mit dem
Vietnamkrieg weil die Amerikaner durch
ihre Stützpunkte in
Deutschland natürlich viele Flüge gingen
hier über Deutschland Soldaten wurden
von hier aus nach Vietnam geschickt und
das war mit einer der Gründe von Gewalt
gegen Sachen und dann die Gewalt gegen
Personen wer war von all den genannten
eigentlich die treibende Kraft Herr
Kraus also erstens ist es richtig
zutreffen wir haben es mit einem grün
Quartett zu tun gehabt und ich würde
sagen die Spinne im Netz war damals
horstmerer horstmer das ist deshalb so
überraschend genau das will ich gerade
anführen denn er galt damals als der
prominenteste APU Anwalt und das war ein
sehr rhetorisch beschlagener juristisch
gut aufgestellter Anwalt und die
Vorstellung dass dieser Anwalt in
Untergrund würde gehen können die hätte
damals vermutlich kaum jemand prnos
iizeren können mit Ausnahme von gutrun
enzlin gutrun enzlin hatte während des
Warenhaus brandstifterpzesses in
Frankfurt
Maler vorher gesagt dass er die
Anwaltsrobe abgeben würde und die Waffe
in die Hand nehmen würde und genau das
ist geschehen ich glaube dass man über
diese vier Personen ja vielleicht eines
noch sagen muss es ist richtig angemerkt
worden dass Andreas Bad das sozusagen
aus einem gewissen Schema heraus aber
die drei anderen genannten nämlich
Meinhof enzlin und Maler sind z.B
Stipendiaten Studienstiftung des
deutschen Volkes gewesen das heißt die
waren dabei eine akademische
eliteposition künftig einnehmen zu
wollen das muss man sich einfach mal
vorstellen das heißt unter dem
Begründern der RAF waren drei staatlich
geförderte Studierende die offenbar das
Zeug dazu hatten wirklich wichtige und
bedeutende Rollen in einer künftigen
Gesellschaft anzunehmen aber die
Kernfrage auf die sie eigentlich
eingehen wollten Bestand glaube ich
darin zu sagen worin lag eigentlich die
Wurzel für die Gründung der ARF und Herr
Töpper hat meineschtens zurecht gesagt
dass man es nur erklären kann wenn man
gleichzeitig über den Vietnamkrieg
spricht und die Rolle der USA in
Deutschland und insbesondere der
amerikanischen Armee deshalb auch die
ersten großen Anschläge im Mai 1972 vor
allen Dingen nicht nur aber vor allen
Dingen auf amerikanische Einrichtung das
aber nur verknüpft wiederum mit der
nicht angehend und angemessen
aufgearbeiteten essvergangenheit mit
anderen Worten es gab so etwas wie eine
Vertrauenskrise ein misstraum gegenüber
staatlichen Institutionen der Regierung
das war bereits in der Studentenbewegung
alles vorhanden aber das ist in gewisser
Weise zugespitzt worden durch die RAF
und dadurch hatte die RAF auch so viele
sympathisierende vor allen Dingen in
studentischen Kreisen universitären
Kreisen wenn gleich sie darüber über
nicht im Wesentlichen h ausgekommen ist
nun wurden ja einige dieser führenden
RAF Leute Bader enlin z.B dann in
Stammheim inhaftiert und um diese
Inhaftierung gibt es ja nach wie vor
auch richtige Kontroversen welche sind
das denn vor die Kontroversen sind
dahingehend dass auf der einen Seite für
die
Justizvollzugsanstalten oder für die
Justiz sein waren das ganz normale
Haftbedingungen auf der anderen Seite
aus der Perspektive natürlich der
Angeklagten und auch vor allem aus der
Perspektive der Verteidiger waren das
einzelhaftbedingungen die es vorher dies
es nach 1945 im bundesdeutschen
Gefängnis noch nie gegeben habe und das
ging dann s weit bis eben zu dem
foltervorwurf oder vernichtungshaft oder
Isolationshaft trifft das ja überhaupt
nicht zu auf Stammheim trifft das ja
überhaupt nicht zu ja gut aber trotzdem
würde ich ja noch mal gerne
differenzieren wollen man muss natürlich
sehen wenn wir uns Köln Ostendorf
anschauen was teilweise ausgeklammert
wird und zwar
me
einelha einem to der wirklich nach5
absolutewöhnlich war und in diesem toakt
saßen nicht nur eben saß neben nicht nur
Ulrike meain sondern sa auch Astrid
Proll das heißt und das waren schon
vollkommen neue Haftbedingungen mit
besonderen
haftstatoten die es so vorher nicht
gegeben hat wir müsen vorell ja aber gut
man muss natürlich sehen in Köln Köln
Ostendorf war es natürlich schon war es
schon besondere Einzelhaft Bedingung die
wirklich herausstachen dagegen Stammheim
das stimmt natürlich Stammheim auf in
der siebten Etage hatten die Häftlinge
schon vollkommen andere haftbedingung
dahingehen sie hatten Radio Fernseh sie
sie sie hatten ja und vor allem Männer
Frauen was vollkommen ungewöhnlich ist
im deutschen strafzug aber trotzdem
würde ich sagen Stammheim ist schon ein
Ergebnis der Proteste der vorherigen
Proteste das heißt es hat vorher schon
in der von von etlichen auch von
etlichen in intellektuellen und
Gruppierung Proteste gegen diese
einzelhaftbedingung gerade im Kontext
von UL gemeinoff gegeben es hat auch
schon etliche Gutachten gegeben von sehr
auch anerkannten Mediziner die darauf
hinwiesen dass die einzelhaftbedingung
so nicht haltbar sein und ich würde
sagen stamheim ist eigentlich schon ein
Ergebnis einer einer bestimmten
Entwicklung und es ist natürlich
Stammheim waren schon besondere
haftbedingung nämlich im positiven Sinne
das muss man schon aber trotzdem ist es
ein Freiheitsentzug ge also sehe zwei
Punkte wesentlich anders erstens glaube
ich dass der Fall Köln-Ossendorf eine
Ausnahme war und zweitens bin ich
Überzeugung dass dieser zusammenchluss
dieser tendenzielle Zusammenschluss
nämlich die Tatsache dass im siebten
Stock in Stammheim die Spitze der RAF
sozusagen gemeinsam aufhalten konnte
stundenlang miteinander reden konnen und
so weiter und so fort dass sie wirklich
ganz
weit
ausgelegte besondere haftbedingung
hatten das war eine taktische Überlegung
eine taktische Überlegung weil man
nämlich diese Leute auch wirklich
Abhören wollte ich gehe davon aus dass
sie abgehört worden sindim
selst ich weiß das ist ein umstrittenes
Thema es ist aber 2007 das letzte Mal
insbesondere von Stefan Aust und anderen
spielredakteuren ganz groß
herausgestrichen worden das geht bis hin
in die sogenannte Todesnacht vom 17 auf
den 18 Oktober das ein umstrittenes
Thema aber man konnte in dieser
Situation diese Kerngruppe von der auch
weiterhin die Entscheidungen ausgegangen
sind was nämlich als nächstes operativ
umgesetzt werden sollte konnte man am
besten abhören und die hatten Dinge
Dinge da dort zu Verfügung die sind kaum
vorstellbar nämlich hunderte zum Teil
über 1000 Bücher pro Zelle die hatten
hunderte von Schallplatten dabei und sie
hatten ja auch einen Rundfunkempfänger
der durch Jan Karl Raspe dann auch durch
die Zellen dann so miteinander
kombiniert und verknüpft worden ist dass
S in der Lage waren Informationen über
rundfunktnachrichten und so weiter
einzuholen also das das ist schon sehr
sehr ungewöhnlich und widerspricht
eigentlich weitgehend diesem allgemeinen
Bild diesem Klischeebild von der
Isolationshaft das ist fast das
Gegenteil der isolationsshaft Herr
Töpper sie waren ja ständiger Beobachter
in Stammheim auch schon während des
Prozesses ging denn da Prozess und Haft
alles mit rechten Dingen zu ja also
erstmal waren es ja wahnsinnige
Sicherheitskontrollen die alle Besucher
alle prozessbesucher über sich ergehen
lassen mussen auch wir Journalisten
mussten die Schuhe ausziehen es musste
alles abgegeben werden was auch nur im
Entferntesten an ein Wurf Gegenstand
erinnerte und dann hatte man ja
natürlich
ganz kurz vor Beginn des Prozesses am 21
mai 75 im Bundestag die
verteidigerrechte ganz entscheidend
geändert es gab das Verbot der
mehrfachverteidigung also ein
Rechtsanwalt durfte nur noch einen ang
klagten äh verteidigen ein Angeklagter
durfte höchstens drei Anwälte haben und
dann vor allen Dingen was ja dann auch
tatsächlich praktiziert wurde äh die
Gefangenen äh wurden ausgeschlossen vom
Verfahren es gab die Bestimmung wenn sie
stören lärmen
das Gericht beleidigen können Sie von
der Verhandlung ausgeschlossen werden
und da ging es nicht immer äh mit
rechten Dingen zu äh vor allen Dingen
die Angeklagten ich habe das ja oft
erlebt haben dann zum Vorsitzenden
Prinzen gesagt wir wollen ja nicht
teilnehmen schließen Sie uns aus und
dann sagte er das können sie von sich
aus gar nicht hier so beurteilen und
bestimmen sie ich kann sie nur dann
ausschließen wenn Sie hier stören und
Lärmen und D haben Sie dann den
Vorsitzenden in der fekalsprache ich
wiederhole das jetzt hier nicht auf das
Übelste beschimpft und sind dann zum
Teil raus und reingetragen worden also
diese krawallszenen die ich da im
gerichtssal erlebt habe das war schon
sehr an der Grenze des Rechtsstaats das
spitzte sich ja dann alles zu im Jahre
77 den General Bundesanwalt Bubak wurde
ermordet der dresner Bankchef ponto
erschossen arbeitgeberchef Schleier
entfuhrt ebenso wie die
lufttansermaschine Landshut die wurde
befreit von der GSG9 Häftlinge in
Stammheim brachten sich um Schleier
wurde daraufhin ermordet also es war
eine deutsche Woche damals im Herbst 77
musste das alles so kommen war das ein
zwangsläufiger weg oder hätte es auch
ganz anders kommen können ich glaube
nicht dass es eine Zwangsläufigkeit gab
sondern es war eigentlich die Spitze
einer langen
eskalationsgeschichte die sich zunehmend
entwickelt hat wir müssen uns ja V Augen
halten dass jede Aktion der EF oder
jeder Anschlag hatte natürlich
entsprechende staatliche Reaktion zur
Antwort sie haben z.B schon darauf
hingewiesen dass die dass das
dass die Strafgesetze und vor allem die
Strafprozessordnung verschärft wurde mit
mit eklatanten Wirkung und Einschränkung
von zentralen Rechten auf der anderen
Seite sehen wir auch den Ausbau der
Sicherheitskräfte das bundeskriminalam
wurde personell und finanziell enorm
ausgestattet das heißt insgesamt finden
wir da auch eine Reaktion des Staates
und ich glaube gerade dieses
Wechselverhältnis ist ein Staat
einerseits und ERF auf auf der anderen
Seite die zu Folge hatte dass natürlich
die EF in ihrer nächsten Aktion wieder
radikaler war hat insgesamt zu ein
systematischen Radikalisierung der
Gruppe geführt und auch zu einer zunehm
Entgrenzung von Gewalt und 77 ist das
Ergebnis dieser darf ich doch noch zwei
Sätze darüber können wir doch lange
diskutieren B ich mir ganz sicher über
den siebten Stock noch stammim nur ganz
kurz es gibt es ist wirklich zweifelhat
ofter ob das wirklich zutrifft dass die
gefängniszähen das würde das ja
implizieren überwacht wurden oder
abgehört wurden ich habe da erhebliche
Zweifel und denke das muss man wirklich
noch weiter erf
aber wir wissen ist dass die Gespräche
zwischen Verteidigern und hfling dass
die abgehört wden das ist
ein
trerwürberg zugegeben dass diese
Abhöraktion tatsächlich stattgefunden
hat und hier müssen wir sehen das ist
ein eklatantes Grundrecht wurde da
aufgoben nämlich das das ist schon also
schon wirklich in der aus D das nicht
das nicht untersten und ich denke 77 ist
eine ein Endpunkt einer langen
eskalationsges wir müssen vielleicht GL
auch noch drauf hinweisen es gab ja die
Hungerstreiks und im Zuge dieser
Hungerstreiks gab's ja dann die ersten
Todesfälle Holger Mainz 74 November 74
und das hat sozusagen noch mal einen
ganz gewaltigen Schub und
Radikalisierung gebracht der ganzen RF
sehr viele
Sympathisanten aber wir müssten sie da
an der Stelle unterbreche will wir
müssen diese ganze Zeit mit einem
bestimmten Begriff versehen näm das ist
die sogenannte zweite Generation gewesen
die dann während die erste Generation ja
noch lebte
von außen versucht hat Aktionen
durchzuführen und deshal Generation war
in Haft die erste Generation war seit
1972 juni
Mai Juni war die im Haft inhaftiert und
die zweite Generation die hat sich im
Wesentlichen herauskristallisiert im
Zusammenhang mit den sogenannten volter
Komitees und dann wiederum motiviert
durch
Reaktionen auf den Tod von Holger Mainz
Holger Mainz ist sozusagen das ganz
einschneidende Erlebnis für die meisten
Mitglieder der zweiten Generation
gewesen und es gab damals eine
Bezeichnung darauf wollte ich eigentlich
hinaus man redete nämlich schon damals
sehr ironisch fast sarkastisch davon das
sei nichts anderes mehr die RAF als ein
Verein zur
Gefangenenbefreiung und zwar eine
gerilla eine befreit die gerila gerilla
so war die Formulierung das heißt sie
hatten gar keine darüber hinausgehenden
Ziele mehr die die erste Generation noch
mit dem Vietnamkrieg Protest gegen
Vietnamkrieg und so weiter für sich hat
beanspruchen wollen das gab es bei der
zweiten Generation nicht mehr sondern
die waren nach innen gerichtet und daran
kann man sozusagen eine Art von
politischen scheitern besonders stark
erkennen die Gefangenen insteimer haben
ja auch ein gewaltigen Druck ausgeübt
auf die Sympathisanten und die
Unterstützer draußen haben sagt ihr
müsst jetzt endlich was machen uns hier
rausholen und der wurde auch äh der
Hungerstreik und der Tod von Holger
Mainz wurde ganz bewusst eingesetzt es
wird tot gegeben hat z.B enzelin
irgendwo im kassiba geschrieben
nur dann bewegt sich der Staat eine
wichtige Rolle für die Kommunikation der
Häftlinge in stannheim spielten ja die
Anwälte reden wir doch mal
über die Anwälte ist denn da das sind ja
einige ganz namhaft Chili später
Bundesinnenminister der der für die
innere Sicherheit später zuständig war
der direkt gewählte Abgeordnete Ströbele
früher alles anzminister später ja
richtig meine ist denn da in Sachen
Anwälte mittlerweile historisch und
juristisch mittlerweile alles klar oder
gibt es auch da noch offene Fragen also
von K ne dem früheren Präsidenten des
Bundeskriminalamtes general bundesan
general buundesanw danke für die
Korrektur stammt die Bemerkung dass die
Rolle der Anwälte das größte Defizit in
der bisherigen Erforschung der RF sei
und man sollte sich fragen woran das
möglicherweise liegt
vielleicht HT es auch damit zusammen
dass man auf diesem Gebiet natürlich
befürchten muss dass diejenigen qua
Profession sich auch sofort zu Wort
melden würden wenn bestimmte Dinge damit
sozusagen ans Licht der Öffentlichkeit
gezerrt werden könnten die vielleicht da
nicht hingehören
es hat aber bereits Mitte der 70er Jahre
eine große Diskussion über die Rolle der
Anwälte gegeben und es hat ja auch
Gerichtsverfahren gegeben und jemand wie
Christian Ströbele saß ja sogar ein
Untersuchungshaft damals wegen des
Verdachts kasiber geschmuckelt zu haben
anderes mehr er ist dann glaube im Jahr
1980 dann zu einer Freiheitsstrafe auf
Bewährung verurteilt worden und das hing
wiederum zusammen mit dem sogenannten
Infosystem also man hatte sich damals
ich glaube im Jahr 7 überlegt dass
aufgrund der mangelten Kommunikation der
mangelten
bindenkommunikation diese Häftlinge die
Zusagen verstreut waren auf
unterschiedliche Justizvollzugsanstalten
unterschiedlichen Bundesländern dass die
irgendetwas bräuchten um miteinander
besser kommunizieren zu können und dafür
waren natürlich die Anwälte in einer
besonderen Weise disponiert we die
verteilpost nicht kontrolliert wurde ja
das ist sicherlich ein ein Thema dabei
aber worauf zunächst mal hinaus wollte
ist der Punkt dass sie eine unglaubliche
Reise Tätigkeit damals abgespult haben
jemand wie Christian Ströbele ist ja
am im Laufe eines Monats bestimmt 20 mal
verreist gewesen in verschiedene JVAs um
die Kontakte zu den RAF heäftigen
aufrechtzalten und das führte dazu dass
eine Infozentrale eingerichtet worden
ist in der Anwaltskanzlei von Kurt
gronewoldt dem Hamburger Rechtsanwalt
der auch RAF Mitglieder verteidigt hat
und dort liefen sozusagen die informativ
STR zusammen und das hat eine enorme
Bedeutung gehabt was den Austausch und
möglicherweise die Anweisung von
bestimmten Dingen anbetraf die nur auf
diesem Weg haben erfolgen können aber da
wurden ja nicht nur Informationen
eingeschmuckelt nach Stammheim
beispielsweise sondern letzten Endes
auch Waffen waren das denn die Waffen
mit denen sich die Häftlinge letzten
Endes dann selbst töteten also ja gut
man muss aber ja natürlich wurden Waffen
hinterher zum Ende eingeschmungelt aber
es waren Kuriere und es waren in der
Regel zwei drei Anwälte die daran
beteiligt waren deshalb habe ich auch
Probleme wenn wir nur sagen die Anwälte
wir müssen glaube ich sehr genau
differenzieren es gab einzelne Anwälte
wie ein Otto schili oder wie auch ein
Robert von plotnit oder auch ein Armin
goldzen es gab ja zahlreiche es lief ja
allein 1977 liefen gegen einzelne
Anwälte geliefen 51 Disziplinarverfahren
gegen anwält das heißt es war ja doch
eine relativ große Gruppe und es gab
natürlich einzelne Anwälte es gab vier
die tatsächlich sich selbst dem dem
terroristischen Kampf anschlossen das
war ein bcker das war frorher schon
hostmerer das war Hag und das war
Müller der lang Jörg lang ne so die vier
dann gab es eine große Gruppe dazwischen
die äh ihre Aufgabe als Verteidiger
wahrnahmen aber schon tendenziell die
Angeklagten die die versuchen dem
Strafanspruch der Staatsanwaltschaft
entgegenzuwirken und hatten ganz
spezifisches Selbstverständnis als als
Anwälte und da gab es natürlich schon
auch einzelne die auch mit der
mit einzelnen Forderung der EF also
gewisse Sympathie hatten um es
vorsichtig zu formulieren dann gab es
aber auch Anwälte wie ein OT sheli
die schon sich stark auch distanzierten
wiederum von der ERF also von daher
würde ich da sehr genau differenzieren
und nicht sagen die Anwälte sondern wir
müssen uns das genau anschauen und was
man aber sagen kann das war aber auch
ein Wechselverhältnis wir dürfen nicht
vergessen dass natürlich die die Pos des
Anwalts in einem terroristenprozess
ausgesprochen schwierig war lesen sie
allein die Betrachtung von Heinrich
Hannover was das bedeutete als
teroristenanwalt zu agieren das war ja
nicht nur dass sie kontrolliert wurden
dass sie im Strafprozess schon
entsprechend behandelt wurden sondern
das bedeutete auch dass sie schon ab
1972 in den Medien dargestellt wurden
als Helfers Helfers von Terroristen sie
wurden wirklich auch diamiert partiell
hatten sie erhebliche Probleme und sie
galten ja tatsächlich als eine Gruppe
der anwäl aber in Wirklichkeit war es ja
viel schlimmerin das überup nicht wenn
ich an der Stelle kurz mich einmischen
darf erstens die RAF ist meinesachens
maßgeblich gegründet worden von einem
Rechtsanwalt von horstmerer und zwar aus
dem sozialistischen anwaltskollektiv
heraus indem Christian Ströbele und
Klaus nicht schließen das alles darf ich
auch mich einmischen dar alle anwte
n habe ich auch nicht damit sagen wollen
das habe ich damit überhaupt nicht sagen
wollen aber diese Art von Relativierung
führt einfach dazu dass die Sachen
verunklärt werden das nämlich wenn man
das erstens feststellt das horstmaler
sousagen der maßgebliche Begründer war
da also ein Anwalt das sind wir Zusagen
beim ersten Anwalt bei dem zweiten sind
wir bei jemanden wie Eberhard Becker
Eberhard Becker war die
Führungsfigur nach 1972 der ist dann
1974 am 4 Februar verhaftet worden ein
Heidelberger Rechtsanwalt und der dritte
Anwalt in dem Zusammenhang ist siefri
Hag siefried HA hat 1976
das ganze Drehbuch verfasst für das was
sich 1977 abgespielt hat und was lässt
sich zu dieser Art quasi staatlicher
Krise geführt hat im sogenannten
Deutschen Herbst das muss man sich
einfach vor Augen führen und wir dürfen
nicht einfach sozusagen diese
selbstlegendierung permanent weiter
verlängern ich glaube dass nach wie vor
das größte Defizit in der öffentlichen
Debatte über die RAF in der Rolle der
Anwälte liegt man darf natürlich nicht
andererseits sagen dass das geh ohne
staatliches Zutun auch erfolgt wäre es
gibt da natürlich auch erhebliche
Defizite auf staatlicher Seite aber man
muss das Beginnen klarer auszusprechen
als das bislang der Vergangenheit man
muss V allem differenzieren und nicht so
sch
Z Anwälte ist der Jurist eigentlich
zuständig hier war es war ja so der
Stammheim Prozess begann im Mai
75 und es ging ja D Monate lang nur
darum dass die Anwälte versucht haben
diesen Prozess zu torped also ja da
wurde gesagt der Prozess ist Fortsetzung
des Krieges mit anderen Mitteln und erst
nach drei Monaten ist es der
Bundesanwaltschaft gelungen die
Anklageschrift überhaupt zu verlesen da
jagte ein
Befangenheitsantrag und eine
besetzungsrüge die nächste also die
haben schon versucht den Prozess tot zu
machen es gab ja nach alldem nachdem
sich die Häftlinge in Stammheim selbst
getötet haben auch schon vorher da noch
zwei weitere Generationen der RAF was
unterscheidet diese Generation von der
für viele legendären ersten Generation
welche Taten welche Ziele herer me Sie
also was ein Unterschied zwischen der
ersten zweiten generationrifft das habe
ich bereits versucht auszuführen die
zweite war eine nach innen Gerichte
Generation die im Grunde genommen das
alleinige Ziel darin gesehen hat die
heftlinge der ersten Generation zu
befreien und die dritte Generation hat
dagegen versucht wiederum um Papiere
auch zu verfassen
Positionspapiere deren Thema war der
anti-imperialismus und sie ist vor allen
Dingen angetreten um
Repräsentanten des
industriell militärischen komplexes wenn
man so will
anzugreifen sie auch umzubringen sie zu
erschießen also Zimmermann beckurz von
Braunmühl dann vom Auswärtigen Amt aber
Herrhausen als Chef der Deutschen Bank
damals und auch Retter würde da in diesf
der treuandusagen in diese Art von von
Schema durchaus noch reinpassen aber sie
haben andererseits keine darüber hinaus
formulierbaren oder erkennbaren
politischen Zielsetzung referiert das
heißt sie sind in einem ganz abstrakten
System stecken geblieben und sie haben
dadurch die Isolation die unfreiwillige
Isolation der RAF noch mehr verstärkt
das heißt ab Ende der 80er Jahre gab es
eine riesenkrise in innerhalb der RAF
ihres Umfeldes die hatten einfach nicht
mehr die Unterstützung von außen und die
liefen Gefahr sozusagen ausgetrockenet
zu werden nehmen wir mal die Fälle als
Beispiel um das zu verdeutlichen die
Fälle Herrhausen Attentat 89 und den
Fall rohwetder Attentat 91 was war das
Besondere das spezifische an diesen
beiden morgen na ja
Herrhausen 30 November 89 kann mich noch
erinnern beim ZF da natürlich abends
gleich eine sonderset gemacht es gab
überhaupt keine Anhaltspunkte wer äh die
Attentäter gewesen sein können dieser
das Attentat war so minoziös geplant und
ohne große Spuren zu hinterlassen da gab
es keine Fingerabdrücke es gab nichts
die Polizei tappte völlig im Dunkeln und
man weiß ja bis heute nicht wer nun
dieses Attentat
eigentlich verübt hat und bei bei bei
Rohwedder war es ähnlich da vermutet man
spricht viel dafür dass der Grams äh der
Schütze war weil man ein Haar von ihm äh
gefunden hat aber das ob der das alleine
ausgeführt daren bestehen doch auch
erhebliche Zweifel gibt's doch auch
Vermutungen verdächte dass es da
Hilfestellung von palästinensischer
Seite gegeben hat da gab's ja Verbindung
RAF zu den Palästinensern und dass eine
solche
Präzisionsarbeit in Anführungszeichen
wie äh Schüsse aus großer Entfernung z.B
oder auch sprengstoffkenntnisse bei der
RAF ja nicht von vornerein vermutet
werden konnten also es gibt jedenfalls
zwei ganz starke Indizien die dafür
sprechen dass man die Möglichkeit dass
andere Kräfte
diese wahrscheinlichen RAF Mordaktionen
durchgeführt oder unterstützt haben dass
diese damit verstärkt werden können also
ich will will folgendes dazu sagen das
erste ist dass insbesondere das
herrhausenattentat eine wenn Sie so
wollen Terrorismus technologische
Besonderheit hohen Ranges war es hat wie
egmund R Koch von der ARD vor zwei
Jahren glaube ich nachgewiesen hat einen
einzigen Anschlag mit dieser Technik
zuvorgegeben und zwar auf den
Staatspräsidenten im Libanon und das war
etwa 10 Tage zuvor verübt worden und das
spricht sehr dafür dass es Unterstützung
gegeben hat durch
Palästinenser denn derjenige der in der
Lage war eine Art von solchenem
technologischen Setting zu entwickeln um
so etwas verüben zu können stammte von
der PFLP und war dann schon dabei
überzuwechseln zu hisbolla oder zu wem
auch immer das ist dann nicht mehr so
genau rekonstruierbar also das spricht
dafür dass es von dieser Seite
Unterstützung gegeben haben könnte das
zweite aber was
ebenfalls immer in der Diskussion
gewesen ist ist die Vermutung dass die
Staatssicherheit der DDR
sozusagen im in ihrem letzten Akt oder
auch noch nachträglich was roherter
anbetrifft wegen treuhandchef und so
weiter und so fort war das nahliegen auf
so eine Überlegung zu kommen so etwas
unterstützt oder auch tatsächlich
umgesetzt haben könnte
diejenige die
zumindest was äh rohwetter anbetrifft
die mororden rohwets anbetrifft dem eine
klare absager hat ist Birgit Hogefeld
gewesen die damalige Kampf und
Lebensgefährtin von Wolfgang Krams der
eben gerade genannt worden ist ich halte
das inzwischen doch möglich dass eine
solche Aktion mit einem
präzisions Gewehr auch von einem RAF
Mitglied wie am 1 April
1991 in Düsseldorf auf dem auf der einen
Seite des Rheinufers hat durchgeführt
werden können das war ja wirklich eine
Art von Leistung aus 60 m Entfernung
abends durch ein
Schloss ja aber die haben ja natürlich
auch üben können und es ist ja soobald
sogar gegangen dass
198182 auch das Gelände von der NVA
zeitweilig RAF Mitglieder zu Verfügung
gestellt worden ist die haben an
panzerfusten geübt und so weiter das
würde ich nicht ausschließen aber die
der die erste der ersteusagen
spektakuläre Fall den wir eben erwähnt
haben nämlich das Attentat auf herhausen
ist noch mal ganz anders gewesen hat
noch größer technische Voraussetzungen
bedurf also Unterstützung für die RAF
aus Palästina und aus der DDR also ich
habe da gewisse Zweifel ich denke gerade
bei der dritten Generation haben wir das
Problem dass wir weder die Täter kennen
dass die meisten dieikte bis heute nicht
aufgeklärt sind warum kennen wir die
Täter nicht und wir kennen die Täter von
den meisten Anschlägen sind bis heute
nicht bekannt das ist natürlich eine
sehr komplexe Frage weil wir müssen
natürlich sehen wer war das denn dritte
Generation wir müssen uns vor Augen
halten die zweit Generation die
wichtigsten wichtige Mitglieder wurden
82 noch verhaftet Z 10 ERF Kampfes müde
müde ERF Aussteiger wir haben
Unterschlupf gefunden in der Deutschen
Demokratischen Republik wer war denn da
noch übrig in der dritten Generation des
Weiteren müssen wir sehen die
rekrutierungsbasis war bei der dritten
Generation wesentlich schwieriger weil
sie tatsächlich nicht mehr auf Akzeptanz
und Sympathie stehßen das hatte zurfolge
dass wir tatsächlich von einer kleinen
Tätergruppe ausgehen müssen bei der
dritten Generation das ist die eine
Sache die die an und ich habe den
Eindruck je weniger wir tatsächlich real
wissen und historisch einordnen können
desto größer werden
Verschwörungstheorien und Hypothesen wo
wir schon sehr vorsichtig sein müssen
ich denke gerade sage ich das natürlich
als Historikerin dass wir da erstmal
Quellen und Belege brauchen e wir diese
Thesen aufstellen und ich denke das ist
schon sehr
überlegenswert ist es mag sein dass es
Kontakte gegeben hat die will ich gar
nicht abstreiten aber ob wir aber ob wir
die sind aber ob wir so weit gehen
können dass wir direkt auch eine ganz
klare Zuschreibung vornehmen können der
einzelnen t da habe ich darf ich den
jetzt auch mal aussprechen geht danke
schön das wäre also das da habe ich
schon gewisse Zweifel und ich finde es
ist gerade unsere Aufgabe als Historiker
und Historikerin dass wir das
hinterfragen und mit Vorsicht erstmal
Reen und nicht so sehr ganz klare
zuschre das tun wir alles und die
verschwörungsthorien W überhaupt mit
Verschwörungstheorien zu tun es gibt ja
ist einfach wirklich nicht zutreffend
dass wir überhaupt nichts über die
Wüsten das ist einfach nicht wir kennen
nur Namen birf nur nein nein das stimmt
einfach nicht wir wir ja wir wir wissen
aber dass Eva Haule und Birgit Hogefeld
z.B diesen an diesem Anschlag beteiligt
waren im Jahr im August 1985 auf die rin
Main airbass und das dafür um das machen
zu können ein amerikanischer ein armer
amerikanischer GI in Diskothek
angebagert worden ist um ih dann
anschließend zu erschießen um sich in
den Besitz seiner Papiere zu bringen um
dann auf die reinen mal das ist ja alles
belegbar das heißt wir haben es gibt
durchaus bestimmte Fenster mit
Konkretionen und sie müssen einfach mal
sprechen mit dem betreffen also wenn sie
z.B mit einer Person wie bergit Hogefeld
sprechen dann kriegen sie eine Ahnung
davon was damals tatsächlich sich
abgespielt haben könnte ich halte es
eher umgekehrt für eine Art von
Verschwörungstheorie nämlich zu glauben
man können alles sozusagen auf ein
nebulöses wir wissen gar nichts und so
weiter verschieben es gibt wirklich
Konkretionen und wenn sie die sich die
Gerichtsakten Anschauen von den
Prozessen ja dann dann komm dann dann
kommen sie ja dann wundert es mich umso
mehr dann kriegen sie nämlich genau
detailliertere Information über die
Dinge die zumindest bekannt sind und das
sind nicht so ganz wenig Herr Töpper wir
wissen wenig aber etwas wissen wir doch
was denn nee man vermutet auch dass es
auch sogenannte feierabendterroristen
gewesen sein könnten diese dritte
Generation die gar nicht mehr im in
Untergrund lebt sondern die gingen einem
ganz normalen Beruf nach und haben
Terrorist und haben
jetzt der Begriff feierabendterrorist
das ja eine Bezeichnung die für die
Revolutionären Zellen eingeführt worden
sind das ist noch eine dritte neben der
RF der Bewegung 2 Juni eine dritte
terroristische Gruppierung gewesen und
für die hat man sozusagen reserviert den
Ausdruck die Bezeichnung Feierabend
aberell also ich stelle fest wir kennen
die meisten Attentäter die meisten
Menschen die der dritten Generation der
RF angehören nicht dann reden wir doch
mal über die Rolle der Behörden also
Ermittler Geheimdienste Justiz ist den
meinen Eindruck richtig dass da nicht
immer effektiv und mit letzter
Konsequenz und auch mit Fehlern behaftet
ermittelt wurde Herr Töpper ja mit
Sicherheit der Verfassungsschutz jetzt
müss man zur Rolle des
Verfassungsschutzes sicher kommen der
spielt ja da bei vielen Attentaten eine
ganz dubiose Rolle sie haben es in ihrem
Eingangsstatement schon gesagt es ging
ja los in Berlin
mit mit dem Urbach ja der hat Waffen und
Sprengstoff an der RF geliefert und
bishinalös bishin zum zum letzten
faumann dem Steinmetz aus wiesb der
angeblich Grams und H
in badkleinen sozusagen den
Sicherheitsbehörden
ausgeliefert hat also die Rolle des
Verfassungschutzes ist sehr dubios und
vielfach sind ja dann auch entsprechende
Leiter im Stammheimer Prozess oder
anderen Prozessen vernommen worden und
die haben sich immer dann auf die
fehlende
Aussagegenehmigung Berufen sodass wir
auch da im Grunde nach wie vor sehr
wenig wissen Frau dival kmann hat ja das
Fehlen von Quellen Akten Dokumenten
benannt ist den in Sachen
Verfassungsschutz da mittlerweile das
wenigstens vorhanden dass man da gucken
kann das wäre sehr schön wenn das
möglich wäre ich glaube eine der größten
problematischen Schritte die vollzogen
worden ist ist die Auflösung des
Berliner Landesamtes für
Verfassungsschutz im Jahre 2000 durch
Eckard wertebach gewesen dem damaligen
Berliner Innensenator der zuvor
Präsident des Bundesamts für Verfassung
in Köln gewesen ist die Obliegenheiten
des Verfassungsschutzes sind da
integriert worden in der anderen
Abteilung
des innensenats aber das was dort an
Akten an Dokumenten aufbewahrt worden
ist seitdem angeblich vernichtet
jedenfalls unzugänglich damit sind all
diejenigen die darüber arbeiten wollen
also gerade Historikerinnen und
Historiker sozusagen vor ein großes
Problem gestellt und das hat
insbesondere mit Dingen zu tun die
mit mit der Problematik des
Verfassungsschutz im Zusammenhang des
Terrorismus insgesamt wiederum verbunden
sind man erinnere nur an den Fall Ulrich
Schmücker Ulrich Schmücker war ein
Angehöriger der Bewegung 2 juni der
angeworben worden war durch einen
verfassungsschutzagenten der eigentlich
vumanführer war namens Michael
Grünhagen und Ulrich Schmücker ist dann
aufgeflogen in seiner eigenen Gruppe und
er wurde dann im Juni 1974 sich
hingerichtet das heißt ein Todesfall
aufgrund ein Mordfall aufgrund gerade
der Verwicklung des Verfassungsschutz
Schutzes und es hat insgesamt vier
Gerichtsverfahren gegeben um das zu
klären und es hat keine Klärung gegeben
und es es würde wirklich zu weit führen
es wäre ein ganzes Thema für eine
Abendsendung um das alles aufräumen zu
wollen müssen sicher auchchena Becker
wäre eine andere Person an der man das
exemplifizieren
könnteau vermutet vermutet also das ist
schon sehr frühzeitig durch die
Staatsicherheit der DDR vermutet worden
äh nämlich ab 1972 gab es Informationen
die bei der Staatssicherheit einliefen
dass virena
Becker wahrscheinlich Informantin sei
wie wie steht es denn nun wenn wir schon
über die Rolle des Verfassungsschutzes
gesprochen haben
um die Rolle der Ermittler die
Kriminalpolizei ist da alles nach besten
Wissen und Gewissen gelaufen in Sachen
RF Fahnung oder gab's da auch Defizite
oder schlichten ergreifen Fehler und
Vers ich glaube da gab es ähnliche
Defizite und Fehler wobei ich trotzdem
noch mal sagen würde es war natürlich
Anfang der 70er Jahre war das natürlich
auch für die Behörden für die
Strafverfolgungsbehörden für die
Sicherheitskräfte ein komplett neues
Phänomen es würde ich auch doch noch mal
in Rechnung stellen dass es auch nicht
so einfach war für die Behörden damit
umzugehen trotzdem hat es erhebliche
Defizite gegeben für mich ist z.B ein
Punkt
warum hat man einzelne V Leute nicht
stärker bzw we man wird sich ja bestimmt
auch mit einem Klaus Steinmetz
auseinandergesetzt haben dann wird man
bestimmt auch Information über die
dritte Generation erfahren haben müssen
über mit Struktur über binstrukturen
warum erfahren wir sowas nicht das ist
natürlich die Frage der größte der
größte Fehler der Polizei war ja ganz
offensichtlich nach der
schleierentführung hatte ja schon die
Kölner Polizei zwei Tage nachdem er
entführt worden ist den Hinweis auf die
konspirative Wohnung im rengraben das
war also eine ganz typische Wohnung in
einem Hochhaus gelegen
mit Zugang zu einer Tiefgarage
und die Mieterin hatte die Miete schon
im Voraus bezahlt auch Strom und Gas und
so weiter wurde alles bar bezahlt also
alles Kriterien die der Herold
entwickelt hatte in seiner rasterfahung
die dafür sprachen dass es da um sich
eine konspirative Wohnung handeln könnte
und die Polizei hat dies fern schreiben
losgeschickt und irgendwo durch
Schlamperei ist dieses Fernschreiben bei
den zuständigen Stellen nicht bearbeitet
worden sonst hätte man Schleier sicher
retten können die Rolle der DDR ist ja
schon erwähnt worden lange dachte man ja
die DDR hätte RAF Leuten nur die
Durchreise gewährt in den Nahen Osten
etwa oder
unterschlupfgeboten heute wissen wir ja
dass sie sie auch trainiert hat hat
damit die DDR die RF bei ihren Morden
gleichsam
unterstützt also ich wäre in der
Hinsicht obwohl ich das in ihrer
Beschreibung teilen würde dennoch
vorsichtig sein wollen also es hat ja
eine anders gelagerte Diskussion um
Karlheinz Kuras gegeben weil sich dann
im Jahre 2009 auf einmal rausgestellt
hat dass Karin Kuras für die
Staatssicherheit gearbeitet hat und
daraus haben
einigeesorg erschossen genau der
benesorg am 2 juni 1967 erschossen hat
äh und daraus haben viele dann gemeint
den Schluss ziehen zu können dass das ja
höchstwahrscheinlich im Auftrag der DDR
der Staatssicherheit oder der SED
geschehen sei das hat sich aber
überhaupt nicht bestätigt im Gegenteil
es lassen sich eine ganze Menge an
Dokumenten finden und deshalb Belege
dafür finden dass sie das als Gefahr
angesehen haben sozusagen genau in
diesen Verdacht zu geraten und ich
glaube auch dass es äh mit
der der Beziehung zwischen der RAF und
der stadssicherheit in mancherlei
Hinsicht ähnlich gewesen ist es hat ja
zu Beginn der 90er Jahre eine lange
Debatte über die sogenannte RAF Stasi
connection gegeben das hing nicht
zuletzt damit zusammen dass Hal diese
zehn untergetauchten RAF Leute die 1980
auf einmal verschwunden waren dann 1990
im Juni in der DDR also der zu Ende
gehen DDR noch haben verhaftet werden
können äh diese Geschichte schien das zu
befeuern aber wenn man sich ein bisschen
detaillierter mit den Unterlagen aus der
äh aus der BSEU befasst dann wird klar
dass im Grunde genommen die DDR sich
auch versucht hat sozusagen im Kontext
ähm ja der osteuropäischen der
kommunistischen oder
staatssozialistischen Länder zu bewegen
und offenbar sich zu manchen
verpflichtet gefühlt hat was sie selber
gar nicht intentional mit oder
willentlich hat mittragen wollen
beispielsweise dass die carlosgruppe
mehrfach also Carlos Johannes Weinrich
und andere in Ostberlin auf auftauchten
und dann einen Anschlag im Jahr 1983 auf
die Maison de France am kudam in
Westberlin verübt haben und es war ganz
klar dass dieser Sprengstoff von Ost
nach West transportiert worden war und
das hätte natürlich den ganzen Kurs der
DDR den damaligen Kurs nämlich auf
Anerkennung internationale Anerkennung
auszusin im Sinne eines zweiten
deutschen Staates das hätte sozusagen
die Reputation gefährdet insofern war
das immer eine ganz zweischneidige
Angelegenheit und ich glaube dass Sie an
dieser Stelle nicht so dumm waren und
unnötige Gefährdung eingegangen sind
andererseits muss man allerdings
durchaus einräumen dass sie konkrete
Hilfen geleistet haben in bestimmten
Phasen mehr in bestimmten weniger aber
schon am Anfang wäre es der RAF
eigentlich gar nicht möglich gewesen
überhaupt von Westberlin die ja
sozusagen damals äh also 1970 sowas wie
eine geopolitische Insel gewesen ist in
den Nahen Osten zu kommen um dort sich
ausbilden zu lassen das heißt die
Ausbildung ist ja nur möglich gewesen
weil die DDR das geduldet oder
unterstützt hat und einen letzten Punkt
dazu Ulrike gemeinhoff war von 1958 an
Mitglied der illegalen KPD gewesen die
konnte immer auf die Unterstützung
hoffen und pochen die sie dann auch
bekam wenn Sie eine Grenze nicht
durchgelassen wurde dann hat sie den
Genossen Milke verlangt dann wurden die
ganz unsicher und wussten nicht was es
das für eine der Milke war im besten
nicht sonderlich bekannt zu dem
Zeitpunkt und dann hat man sie
durchgelassen ja sehen Sie das anders
fraual Kerkmann also ne ich würde fast
sagen es ist genauus ich würde das um
einen um einen Punkt noch erweitern
wollen ich glaube auch dass man hat
diese Durchfahrt gewährt das trifft
tatsächlich zu und man hat auch hinter
die auf die asteiger aufgemacht aber ich
glaube ein ganz wichtiges Anliegen war
Informationen zu erfahren was die EF
plant ich glaube das war ein ganz
wichtiges Motiv die anderen Position ich
sehe das ganz genauso dass man da
aufpassen muss dass wir da nicht zu
einem doch sehr vorschnellen Urteil
kommen die DDR der
Staatssicherheitsdienst hat ja z.B mit
dem Geheimdienst im Jemen
zusammengearbeitet hat die dort
ausgebildet ja so habe ich es jedenfalls
in Akten gelesen sogar teilweise dann
sechsis da gesprochen die RF sind ja im
Jemen gewesen haben da eine militärische
Ausbildung bekommen also die DDR der
statsicherheitsdienst wusste immer schon
genau was die so vorhatten
wahrscheinlich sind die auch denke ich
mal abgehört worden also ich gebe Ihnen
da recht der Staat sicherheitsdient war
daran interessiert zu erfahren was haben
die vor
welche Attentate sind demnächst geplant
um
da auf der sicheren Seite zu sein die
dritte Generation der RAF hat ja im
Jahre 98 offiziell die Auflösung der RAF
verkündet weil sie die ursprünglichen
Ziele als nicht mehr erreichbar
angesehen hat hat so gesehen der Staat
also letzten Endes
gewonnen das war ja von Anfang an klar
dass der Staat letzten Endes gewinnen
würde das waren ja wenn Sie so wollen in
der unmittelbaren quasi militärischen
Konfrontation ganz ungleiche
Kontrahenten das es konnte nicht anders
ausgehen aber damit ist natürlich noch
was anderes gemeint dass eigentlich
diese vermeintliche Legitimität die
diejenigen die den bewaffneten Kampf äh
begonnen hatten glaubten ins Spiel
bringen zu können dass die auch nicht
mehr vorhanden war und es gab sowas wie
eine Art von innerem spaltungsprozess in
der RAF ab etwa 1990 es gab sozusagen
zwei Meinungsführer der eine ist Klin
selvo gewesen
der bereits damals sich mit Überlegung
offenbar getragen hat dass die RAF
sozusagen ihren Zenit nicht nur
überschritten habe sondern tendenziell
aufgelöst werden müsse und die
Kontrahentin war Brigitte monhaupt die
ja von Andreas Bader und gutrun enzlin
für den Fall ihres Todes dann als die
nachfolgende Chefin sozusagen bereits
deklariert worden war und die das auch
gemeint hat so handhaben zu sollen und
das führte dann auf über verschiedene
Schritte dazu dass nämlich einzelne dann
auch im Laufe der 90er Jahre
freigelassen wurden und es gab ein ganz
wichtiges Treffen im August
1997 in Zürich in der sogenannten Roten
Fabrik dort sind ehemalige Mitglieder
der roten Brigade aus Italien und
ehemalige RAF Mitglieder
zusammengekommen und haben darüber
diskutiert öffentlich diskutiert sollen
wir dann no irgendwas weitermachen soll
wir das aufgeben und so weiter und so
fort und relativ bald danach nämlich am
20 April
1998 wurde dann die Auflösung verkündet
Horst Herold der ehemalige Präsident des
Bundeskriminalamtes war damals soweit
gegangen weil das ja nun das Tagesdatum
von Hitlers Geburtstag war zu meinen das
sei völlig unglaubwürdig ihr können sich
nicht vorstellen dass eine RAF
Generation so unhistorisch sei um an
diesem Tag noch ihre auflesung Auflösung
bekannt geben zu wollen aber es hat sich
bestätigt bislang spricht nichts dagegen
und trotzdem trotz dieser
Selbstauflösung hören wir und lesen wir
zu unserer Überraschung dass im Jahre
2015 dNA Spuren von Raf Leuten bei
mehreren Überfällen nachgewiesen wurden
sind sie also trotz alledem noch immer
unter uns und was wollen sie eigentlich
ja das ist in der Tat spannende große
Frage äh aber man vermutet äh dass das
sozusagen Beschaffungskriminalität ist
äh denn die können ja schwer in die
Rentenversicherung Bund einzahlen und
sind ja sicher jetzt auch äh schon nah
am Rentenalter dass die also das Geld
aus diesen äh Überfällen brauchten äh um
ihren Lebensunterhalt zu bestreiten so
ist jedenfalls äh die Vermutung äh der
RAF Experten äh aber das jetzt eine
vierte
Generation da heranwächst das glaube ich
nicht nun hat sich ja die zuständige
Sonderkommission schon im April diesen
Jahres 2016 regelrecht
aufgelöst fragt man sich warum muss man
denn in Sachen Linksterrorismus nicht
mehr ermitteln weil der
Rechtsterrorismus Stichwort Aktion
Freital alle Kräfte bündelt und
erfordert also ich glaube auch ich würde
es sehr unterstre reichen was sie sagen
dass eine vierte Generation der ERF
nicht gibt ich glaube auch das ist eine
reine
Beschaffungskriminalität also von daher
stellt sich die Frage
der der Auflösung schon vor dem
Hintergrund der veränderten historischen
Kontexte also ich denke schon dass wir
mittlerweile eine starke Verschiebung
haben wobei ich noch einen Satz
nachfügen möchte zu dritten Generation
man hat ja schon no versucht in den
letzten Jahren der dritten Generation
auch noch Kontakte auch international
zum zu Aktion direkt herzustellen diese
Kontakte waren ja nicht sehr erfolgreich
für die dritte Generation da die Aktion
direkt in Frankreich noch weniger
Unterstützung hatte als die dritte
Generation EF in in in Deutschland das
heißt also es war auch tatsächlich der
Zenit war überschritten ich denke das so
zum Rechtsterrorismus das ist natürlich
ein ganz neues großes
Thema ich denke eine gewaltige
Herausforderung für den Staat wenn man
sich jetzt vorstellt dass doch eine
ganze Reihe von früheren RAF Angehörigen
R ftätern freigelassen worden sind jetzt
unter uns leben auch ihren Berufen
nachgehen oder schon in Rente sind fragt
man sich ja wie gehen die mit ihrer
eigenen Geschichte um bereuen Sie das
eine oder andere oder sagen Sie wir
haben richtig gehandelt wie wie können
wir uns da es ist ja ein verpfuscht ein
Rückblick auf ein verpfuschtes Leben
letztenendes sehen Sie das sehen viele
das oder sagen Sie wir haben richtig
gehandelt ich würde als er interessieren
was sie mit Rente meinen na ja was die
Beschaffungskriminalität ist ja ein
Faktor okay ja nein die meisten von
ihnen sind hz4 Empfänger ja also das ist
einfach so und man hat ja sozusagen
diejenigen die als
ehemalige
verkehren während des Prozesses gegen
virena bcker sozusagen Revue passieren
sehen können ja und dort sind ja die
meisten von ihnen aufgetreten haben
geschwiegen wie sie das fast immer tun
es gibt nur ganz ganz wenige ausn an
Peter jürgenburg und ansonsten war es
das schon fast und äh und ja es gibt
jemanden der versucht hat sozusagen den
kernspruch aus der auflösungserklärung
äh zumindest individuell auf seine Weise
zu drehen das ist der bereits erwähnte
delvoo der sozusagen als parole oder als
Credo vor sich herträgt Rebellion ist
gerechtfertigt auch wenn wir gescheitert
sind ja damit werden aber meines
Erachtens auch die zusammen hänge
verwischt insofern nämlich weil dann
doch irgendwie in einer Art von
positiven traditionsstrom die RAF
angesiedelt bleibt es gibt also da fehlt
es mir wirklich an einer qualitativen
Distanzierung gegenüber dem und er war
immerhin beteiligt ja an dem Überfall
auf die deutsche Botschaft im Frühjahr
1975 da sind ja zwei
Botschaftsangehörige bei erschossen
worden sind auch zwei RAF Mitglieder zu
Tode gekommen aber das war etwas äh was
man ja nun keineswegs unter Protest und
Revolte einfach verbuchen kann sondern
das ist eine klare terroristische Aktion
gewesen also ich finde das nach wie vor
da ein Defizit existiert und das größte
Defizit besteht aber meineschtens darin
dass die meisten der Kommunikation und
den kommunikationswünschen vollständig
entziehen und diejenigen die beginnen
oder sich mit Gedanken tragen aus dieser
Art von Schweigekartell ausbrechen zu
wollen die werden dann aufgesucht und
werden
entsprechend gedrängt um Gottes Willen
doch den Mund zu halten und man kann
sich ja vorstellen wie das ungefähr
ausschauen mag dass nämlich man sich
gegenseitig sozusagen unter Kontrolle
hält wenn du was sagst dann sage ich was
über dich und dann wird dieses und jenes
fast wieder aufgemacht das heißt man hat
sich gegenseitig auch bis zu einem
gewissen Grad in der Hand also Stichwort
Schweigekartell mit der Bitte um eine
kurze Antwort Hinweise auf die
Ergreifung der noch flüchtigen Täter der
dritten Generation sind von den in
Freiheit befindlichen exrf Leuten nicht
zu erwarten ein Satz ich glaube sie
praktizieren heute noch genau die die
Position von Rike meinhoff zwischen uns
und staatsverfolgungsbören und Staat
eine klare Trennlinie zu ziehen ich
glaube nicht dass sie aussagen werden
sie werden das Schweigekartell aufrecht
erhalten das Schweigekartell
aufrechterhalten das ist das Schlusswort
meine Damen und Herren geschichte ist
die Lüge auf die man sich geeinigt hat
so sagte es vol wir haben versucht das
völlig anders zu sehen ihnen dreien
danke ich sehr für ihre interessanten
Ausgaben und Ihnen liebe Zuschauer danke
ich für ihr Interesse bleiben sie uns
[Musik]
treu